support for answer the Internet is
brought to you by manscaped introducing
the lawnmower 3.0 it's the third
generation trimmer with skin safe
technology so you'll be Nick free the
Nick freeze import cover II one's gotten
those snakebites on their nuts and
they're just the worst they bleed like a
head wound
so get your lawnmower 3.0 today get it
at manscape calm for 20% off and free
shipping with the code internet 20 your
balls will thank you hi everybody I'm
Phoenix Marie and I'm gonna answer the
internet debate the internet if you
could have one person airy or do
play-by-play of you having sex who would
it be
James Earl Jones yeah she took that dick
that's right because my voice can goes
where I can go and I like that much more
what do you think is the oldest
somebody's been when they've had sex my
ex actually shot a scene for Naughty
America and it was the two girls
they're both 87 years old on camera and
he like take them down so there you go
and they're extra Goldeneye America and
like they they were into it too they
liked each other like so I do like
Gaines wave I don't know if you know
what that is is shockwave therapy to
help with erectile dysfunction I get
guys they're like 85 years old coming in
they're like I still want to [ __ ] Mike I
got you know a young kid yeah oh my I'm
only 38 so she thinks we're both
supposed to stop now guys I'm sorry
would you rather buy a hundred
duck-sized horses are one horse-sized
duck I mean obviously a little [ __ ]
horse sized duck kick that [ __ ] just
kick him I'm not do you see him Amazon
right looks fresh you have a choice
between a sum of money and world peace
how much money would it take for you to
give up world peace listen I don't have
a number right like I have my own money
so I don't have to worry about giving up
world peace
hey what if I offer you like a hundred
billion dollars I mean obviously [ __ ]
roll pieces you can turn to any movie
into a porn with the same cast from the
movie which movie are you picking
interviewed the vampire Tom Cruise now
is it paedophile cuz that girl's only
little I don't know maybe not her in
that part okay
make her older guys would you watch a
porn with the hottest girl from your
high school if the dude in it was her
dad no I love her I'll flip her later
how much is too much for a height
difference in relationships the majority
uh I don't know I did it shorter guys
some guys like girls with really long
legs and like when I put heels on them
like six two so everyone's got a
different answer
I don't oh there you go I mean I'd say
five foot would be five three will be
the lowest if you could bang a ghost who
would it be
Casper of course he's so friendly again
this might be too young I don't know hey
listen I mean he's ghosts I could say
Slimer I mean he skulls hot dogs in his
mouth I mean there's holes hot dogs
anyone anyway would you rather be an
extremely good-looking paralyzed person
or a hideous fully functional person I
mean listen give me some wheels I'm in
this [ __ ] would you rather be falsely
accused of a murder or never be able to
stop coming Wow
I'm gonna definitely say falsely accused
of a murder yeah I want to come home
time guys I come probably seven times a
day and I'm not lying
yeah that's a minimum otherwise I'm not
a nice person yeah okay here we go guys
the next and I like go get the coffee
and I'm like oh wait I can do this again
cool great awesome Hitachi's ruin
everything
if you could pick any character from a
TV or a movie to be your college
roommate who would it be
who hmm patrick Star spongebob Patrick
I think it's cool if you were born with
action-figure hands awesome stuck in the
same position forever what would it be
actually I do this one cuz I fist a lot
of girls like this so write and ask you
gotta like turn guys okay and if you're
gonna do the squirt thing you're just
going like that and you're good now do
you man sir what would you give up first
drinking watching sports are coming
drinking too much
I'm can't see Chiefs in been since 96 I
knew of what you've met at my homes come
on oh yeah exactly
you understand Brady leg is not gonna
win anymore they're not gonna give them
anymore
you can thank you yeah that's right I
think it's my homes turn please would
you rather sit down with your parents
and watch every sexual encounter you've
ever had or sit by yourself to watch a
sex tape of the night they concede you
oh damn so I'm gonna say I'd rather
watch had them watch me than me watched
them like I've walked in when I was a
little kid I was like but I gotta go you
know everyone's walked in on the parents
no I mean actually my dad probably like
whoa you can do that that's so weird
and then I look at my mom she's like no
actually my mom was like what do you
know for I was like anal and she's all
that's disgusting I'm like oh sorry
poor dad that's a lie you're not gonna
find I'm not like she's all nope 38
years and I'm not doing I'm like all
right there you go there's your answer
you